psoriasis is a debilitating disease
affecting more than 6 million Americans
once thought of as simply a skin disease
psoriasis is increasingly recognized as
a serious disease with a significant
impact on quality of life and emotional
well-being
what causes psoriasis and what do we
know about the disease although the
exact etiology of psoriasis is unknown
it is thought to be multifactorial
involving both environmental and genetic
factors
recent evidence suggests that immune
dysregulation may contribute to the
inflammation in psoriasis leading to
excessive keratinocytes production and
formation of psoriatic plaque
it is still unclear what triggers the
immune dysregulation but the process is
now understood to involve the
participation of T lymphocytes and a
number of specific cytokines they
express or that affect them
to become activated naive t-cells must
first undergo a multi-step process that
includes interactions with other cell
types the inflammatory process is
thought to begin when an
antigen-presenting cell such as a
dendritic cell is activated by an
antigen in the skin the dendritic cell
travels to a lymph node where it
interacts with the naive T cell in a
process that involves antigen
presentation as well as necessary
co-stimulatory signals this process
results in the transformation of the T
cell into an activated memory T cell
because it remembers the antigen to
which it has been exposed next fallo
cell proliferation and migration of T
cells through the circulation to the
site of the inflammation in the skin
during this phase migration and
trafficking of these cells through the
bloodstream involves adhesion molecules
such as ICAM one following T cell
extravasation into the skin other immune
components such as cytokines play an
important role in the inflammatory
cascade these chemical messengers
including TNF alpha and interferon gamma
are secreted by memory t-cells and lead
to keratinocyte hyper proliferation and
subsequent formation of psoriatic
plaques
in addition cytokines interleukin x' 12
and 23 are released by dendritic cells
and contribute to the activation of
t-cells which are thought to perpetuate
the inflammatory process
you
while our understanding of immuno
pathogen assist psoriasis has improved
based on recent research the exact cause
remains unknown and there is no cure
some researchers believe that a more
thorough understanding of the
inflammatory nature of psoriasis may
provide further insights into the
prevention and treatment of this disease